one thing that i'm really starting to
notice
is that it's becoming extremely
difficult not to spend
all of our time on social media on the
internet and all of that
during these times of isolation as if it
wasn't already a huge
problem and it kind of makes sense when
you think about it if people are locked
inside their houses
all day long then obviously they're
going to start gravitating towards these
pleasure boxes
these entertainment cubes and i don't
want to be another video that's just
like
smartphone bad books good but i do think
that the growing
influence of these algorithm-heavy
websites
needs to be talked about because the
majority of these websites or these apps
are designed from the ground up to be as
addictive
as possible you know i just finished
watching the documentary the social
dilemma on netflix and it really
reminded me of some of the things that i
also read in digital minimalism by cal
newport and that is that for these big
tech companies
our attention is their currency you know
we're not the customer we're the product
the customer of facebook and instagram
and whatever
are the third-party companies that have
advertising on their platform and that
gets advertised to us
so it's in big tech's best interest to
keep us hooked on these apps for as long
as possible and that's why they're so
algorithm-dependent because there hasn't
been a tool in history
that has been so powerful at predicting
what you're going to do next
what your likes and what your dislikes
are what videos you're most likely to
binge
what topics you're most interested in
these websites are
unbelievably good at just serving you a
video that you're likely to watch
and that you're likely to waste a lot of
time on you know maybe this video
this type of self-improvement content is
something that you're likely to binge
which is why
i ended up on your youtube homepage
these algorithms are powerful
and i don't want to be all doom and
gloom about this you know i'm not saying
that there's nothing
we can do about it but i think it is
important to be conscious of our
behavior
because these apps rely so heavily on
our unconscious behavior
so what's the solution it would probably
be pretty lonely if we just you know cut
ourselves off from technology altogether
and then also just lived in an empty
house by ourselves for months and months
and months until this whole thing blows
over but at the same time we do have to
be proactive with finding solutions i
think otherwise our internet use is
gonna get so out of control and occupy
like 90 of our day and when the pandemic
is actually
over we're still gonna have this habit
of just waking up and going on the
internet for like
90 of the day and then going to bed and
i'm not sure if i have
the answer to this problem because
everybody's life is so different so i
figured it would be really cool to talk
to my friend and fellow creator
nathaniel drew
uh about this issue and try to get his
thoughts on maybe some solutions
and hopefully through our conversation
you guys can start thinking about a game
plan that makes sense for you
and your life so nathaniel what do we do
about this problem
there is a lot we can do about it you
know this is nowhere near a sort of
situation where it's like
out of our control that's it we live in
a dystopia like
i'm seeing more and more people wake up
to this and i find that very encouraging
and i have felt in myself over the last
year particularly because of the
imbalances that i feel my life and in
the world
that i am also making an effort to not
feel
like i'm at the mercy of this machine
learning that is deciding everything for
me
i do believe i have control over this to
a certain extent
and if that means that at times i need
to remove myself from it or
change things up then so be it but i
have control over that
right off the bat i love this point that
nathan makes you know my entire last
video was about how having an internal
locus of control
is extremely important when everything
around us seems to be so out of our
control
we can't control the pandemic we can't
control the economy you know we can't
control
a lot in our lives but we do have
control over our actions and our
behaviors
and i feel like social media's influence
on us is a great example of something
that we have the power to be proactive
about
i think this is really interesting
internal locus yeah
yeah dude you know if you're trying to
break out of an algorithmically
controlled life i would say there's two
things to take into consideration
one there's a level of personal
accountability take a level of ownership
over your decisions and how you're
spending your time
like there's no alternative to that you
can there's no workaround but there's
also
a level of understanding that helps me
feel a little bit more
self-compassionate
in when i recognize that okay i am
susceptible to
distractions and bright brightly colored
interesting looking thumbnails let's say
um and so i
take steps to sort of remove it from or
add friction right like
make it make it all a little bit less
accessible and i think it's been a
process dude i say this all the time i
feel like i sound like a broken record
but
i'm always trying things out to see what
works and it's been a multi-month
multi-year process of me trying to
figure out
what is the life that i want to live and
what is the level of information
consumption that is right for me
i find i have to just check in with
myself regularly
constantly almost so if how we spend our
time is our choice
and we know that we probably shouldn't
be spending as much time on social media
i think it's really important that we
take out a good old-fashioned pen and
paper
and try to think about how we would
ideally like to spend our day
you know how much time do you want to be
spending on social media and you know
maybe that's not zero
maybe you do want to engage in these
like you know pleasures a little bit but
be intentional with it
try to plan out how much time you
actually want to be spending
and be conscious of that decision
otherwise
youtube and reddit and facebook are
really good at just stealing your time
from you if you don't have a plan and
once you've made this plan once you've
kind of designed the structure around
your social media use
i think there's a lot of tools i think
apple has one if you have an iphone
android has one if you have an android
where you can actually set timers on
certain apps
i'd highly recommend you look up you
know a youtube video on how to set
timers on apps depending on what os you
have
that'll add an element of friction and
help you stay
on your goal yeah i think that's a good
that's a really like level-headed
approach because i feel like so many
people they get so fed up with like all
the control that social media has over
their lives and they
uh they get very extreme about it so
they'll like
smash their phone with a hammer or like
install like blockers on their
computer and they're like oh i'm
deleting my facebook i'm never going
on any of these apps again yeah i'm
retaking control of my life but i feel
like
99 of people who do that end up kind of
like bouncing back they
underestimate the gravity of like what
this social media is
replacing in your life if you find
yourself constantly escaping from
reality
then you need to work really hard to
create a reality you don't want to
escape from
it's easy to forget about this being too
externally focused
thinking there's solutions in terms of
systems or
how i should live my life or what i
should be doing with my time
that will solve everything and that is a
part of the
equation but it's not the whole thing to
get to a place
where you're living a life that you
don't necessarily want to escape from
there's an internal element i don't know
if that makes sense it's sort of like a
what is your relationship with yourself
yeah i think a lot of us
use technology as a form of escapism
which i can totally relate to by the way
i know personally that especially in
times like this
when i try to just not spend all day on
facebook or instagram or even youtube
sometimes an anxiety or discomfort
starts to stir within me and it's it's
very uncomfortable
it actually feels almost physically
painful to
you know remove yourself from technology
and just have a more
boring day or at least a less
stimulating day
but i think it's extremely important
that we engage with this side of
ourselves
i think it's extremely important to
really feel this boredom
and to feel this anxiety so that we can
actually work through it
and stop escaping from it all the time
and there are a couple things that you
can do
to sort of properly work through these
emotions and become
very become a lot more okay with
being alone being cut off from this
constant flow of information one of my
favorite ways of doing that
is mindfulness learning how to just
observe your negative thoughts
from sort of a third person perspective
and also journaling
writing down things that you are
concerned about and writing down a game
plan for how you might overcome those
obstacles
and honestly just get outside get out of
your house go in nature there are safe
ways to leave your house
and i honestly think that one of the
best ways to clear your head
is to sort of reconnect with that primal
aspect of you
go outside go for a walk in nature go
for a hike you know exercise as much as
possible
there are ways that you can spend time
away from social media apps that are
actually kind of fun
and will make you feel a lot better
that's why i'm saying that this period
of uh lockdown and time alone
it was painful and was difficult
especially uh early last year but i'm
really really grateful that i went
through this
because it has completely shifted how i
spend time with myself
and i think i kind of saw more clearly
than i've ever seen before that
it all starts from there so if i can't
solve that
no matter what i try to do in a
self-improvement sense
i will never get to that sort of
lifestyle that makes me feel like i
don't need to escape
ultimately though even the fact that
you're watching this video
hopefully has caused you to think about
the role that you want social media
and the internet in general to play in
your lives and also be more
cognizant of the fact that a lot of
these websites that you like to spend
time on
are profiting greatly from your
attention they want to keep you hooked
into them as much as possible
even at the expense of your mental
health and your overall sense of
well-being and hopefully all this will
help you
spend your time in a way that you want
to be spending it
not how lord zuck wants you to spend it
[Music]
so as many of you guys know one of my
favorite ways to consume content
without any algorithm involved is by
listening to
audiobooks and by far the easiest way to
do that
is by using today's video sponsor
audible and if you're looking for
something to listen to
on audible one of my favorite books of
all time in terms of just
how helpful it was to me is digital
minimalism by cal newport and in this
book
cal newport really offers so much
insight as to
you know what the entire goal of big
tech social media companies actually
is i had so many aha moments and it
really helped me
leverage technology to help me achieve
my goals
rather than keeping me a slave to it and
for those of you who don't know
audible is the leading provider of
spoken word entertainment and audiobooks
ranging from best sellers to celebrity
memoirs
motivation productivity and so much more
like original entertainment and even
podcasts audible recently launched their
newest plan
audible plus and with audible plus you
get access to their
entire plus catalog which is filled with
thousands and thousands of select
originals
audiobooks and podcasts including
ad-free versions of popular shows
as well as exclusive series personally
one of my favorite things about audible
is that if you decide to cancel your
membership at any point
you still keep your entire library of
audiobooks
including the audiobooks that you got
for free using their credit system
so it's kind of a no-brainer so to sign
up for your free 30-day trial
click the link in the description below
visit audible.com
better ideas or text better ideas to
500-500
once again click the link in the
description below or text better ideas
to 500 500
expand your mind learn something new and
as usual
have a great time so usually this is the
part of the video where i'm like if you
like this video make sure you hit like
because when you hit like the algorithm
blesses me and it shoves my bald head
into other people's home pages helping
them out which also helps me
out so it's a win-win for everybody but
even just saying that
seems instinctually counterproductive to
what i just said i don't think it
is as counterproductive as i think it is
because
people are gonna get a video on their
homepage no matter what
so it might as well be a video that's
telling people to
think about how much time they want to
be spending on youtube
however the next part if you're lurking
here consider subscribing and hitting
the bell icon so you don't miss future
videos
yeah let's scrap that you can subscribe
if you want to but
really think about whether you want to
be hitting that bell icon on
any youtuber in general because
you know i would hate to be the person
who interrupts a chess game with your
father
or a conversation with your grandma you
know me being like
hey get off social media and it's
notification to tell you to get off
social media it's completely
counterproductive
anyways that's all for today thank you
so much for watching and we'll catch you
in the next video